trending this afternoon did you see the
interview
a two-hour bombshell tv event last night
with prince harry and his wife megan and
oprah winfrey
this afternoon there is still no formal
response from the royal family to the
revelations and the accusations
ian lee reports i had three
conversations with my grandmother
television queen oprah winfrey spent two
hours digging into why prince harry and
meghan
left royal life for a new life in the
u.s did you blindside the queen
no i've never blindsided my grandmother
i have too much respect for her
did you leave the country because of
racism
it was a lot it was a large part of it
the couple says
megan's mixed race was a worry for some
british royals when she became pregnant
concerns and conversations about how
dark his skin might be when he's born
and you're not going to tell me who had
the conversation
i think that would be very damaging to
them harry and meghan blame
tabloids for spreading lies and the
monarchy for not refuting them
did you make kate cry no
the reverse happened megan says the
palace promised to protect her
but left her open to a painful character
assassination
i would sit up at night and i was just
like i don't understand how
all of this is being churned out and i i
just didn't
i just didn't want to be alive anymore
so were you
thinking of harming yourself were you
having suicidal thoughts
yes this was very very clear harry says
more hurts came when they officially
stepped away as senior royals
my family literally cut me off
financially and i had to afford to
afford security for
us i've got what my mum left me and
without that we would not have been able
to do this
as megan and harry pulled back the
curtain on their new life in california
they had a surprise to go
revealing archie will have a little
sister this summer
an uplifting moment in the midst of a
royal family feud
ian lee cbs news london